[Music]
and the Golden Globe goes to all right
sure sure are you gonna be feeling great
because you know this is loosely based
on your directors life I know you
probably wanted reddit to win but the
movie wins and you didn't and even me
get that like that's hers you know she's
this is all her and she's put so much of
ourselves into it
not even necessarily in an
autobiographical sense but just every
every grain of her is is in this and she
works very hard on making it as great as
it is I'm so great on a night like this
nothing like that right
I know okay can we talk about the Oprah
speech Oprah for president I mean really
or a president right seriously I think
she'd be amazing right
were you in the audience when it yes a
good place we were in the UH yeah
everyone's in the audience and we're all
sort of like she's I mean we know she's
incredible and then I just I loved the
speech I loved the clarity of it I you
know I loved what she had to say she so
the way she I think it's also not just
the content of what she says but the way
she delivers something is so inspiring
words yeah I know so I like that you
know she made sure to kind of say there
are wonderful women in this industry and
there are wonderful men to and it's all
about of supporting each other so I was
great it just couldn't be more perfect
right it's just perfect